that emergency evacuation announcement
please know this meeting will go
recorded we inquire to evacuate the
building would you please leave the room
by the doors to the fire stone staircase
piece of boat and rails in case the
stairs or which are slippery you think
what is unable to use the stairs when
they please allow others to exit them
before they go to the escaped or were
they from in vehicle assistance our
assembly point will be in the public car
park in the side of the city sweet
please do not delay your evacuation to
collecting belongings and please do not
return to the building that's what you
permission to do so by council stuff
right good evening so apologies for
absence everyone's future yeah so do you
doin say something yeah I just wanted to
introduce people to know yeah oh sorry
yes yeah Laura's left to have a baby I
understand she still had it oh what a
job she left when she did up
penny on the sax man she left on Friday
lovely and packing final is taken over
from her while she's of three years long
has a lot of experience in that sort of
fielder's I'm sure when you chat with oh
you'll find out okay thank you very much
for that too but non members attending
to announce minutes of the last meeting
held on the twenty-fourth of March is it
your wish I sign a visitor record thank
you any declarations of interest okay if
anything turns up during the meeting
please advise us at that time masses
refer to the executive and reports from
other committees there are none so ago
spoke to item 6 please performance
report on key performance indicators for
the January to March 2015 6 remotes
so starting then from page 54 36.3
anybody got 6.3 the only one item i had
another vision really position to
explain is a bit disjointed about the
last two items if it was one saying that
the collection rate is up I appreciate
that for the business rates collective
and the other one saying so it is its
collective sinking yeah waiting is
characteristic up competitor figure but
the other one saying is down I think
that's right anyway but just wonder why
there is a disparity between the two
that's why I read it anyway I think my
white one is value in actual cash yeah
and the a bit part our ability to to
practice let's reduce because there's
less rateable value on that line okay
that's fine happy with that ok any other
questions on that right moving through
does anybody wish to raise anything
through the reports
no nothing in the report at all okay
just once in serious miss please I think
it is what saying there's a new man
doing the same of assistance grants
Matthew somebody content discerning
really good it so your improvement in it
and your huge an andrew andrew paul
matthews Andrew it's a free Matthews
before they're fascinating to pass on
their knowledge management Andrew
Marshall there you go she wasn't but I
was quite impressed i [ __ ] up with
loads of queries and he got the answers
instantly which is a nice change good
okay right sometimes straight into a
report item seven anybody got any on
this please I'm thank you later yeah
it's good to see that this Authority
school system I saw like I so basically
these reports have been rubbish quite a
few months and it's good to see they're
still on every single page I've got
problems with on this particular report
I can't believe it if we start on page
two if you
the top now developing dubs a new local
plan it's been going for 18 months and
we are any ten percent complete Scott
understand boy next time parallel adopt
community infrastructure levy charge was
scheduled that one's bigger sat sep
tember 2013 we've managed to get to
thirty five percent complete was it
takes a lot and we've lost not blown
away that way the corporate crime 4g
development it and deliver approach
Valley Living Landscape down here it's
got it is twenty percent complete and it
started in September 2014 I actually had
a meeting with the essence Wildlife
Trust to the floods month had last week
so I don't quite work out how that can
be so far advanced then we go on to the
improve air quality of a nissan sentra
funded DK declaration of air quality
vaginal area we've declared one so i
really worthwhile can't get a response
page by pages that are rounded up
through I don't remember if I were how
probably said it were which is liquid
hydrogen later on fog that projected on
the first page I mean at lidl comment
it's absolutely the case that the
process of preparing and getting to the
adoption of any development plan is as
members will be aware some more tortuous
and long-winded process and in the case
of both the but the job and the
allocations plan both of those plans to
substantially longer
was anticipated not least because both
were subject to legal challenges and
those legal challenges to some
considerable amount of time to deal with
and indeed a significant amount of
officer resource the end result is that
the local plan is taking the new local
plans ultimately replaced the core
strategy and the allocations plan was
taken longer to get going man was
originally anticipated the other point
I'd make is that as members will also
wear whole plans are evidence-based and
therefore there's a substantial amount
of work that has to be carried out in
the background to update the evidence
base and you'll see there that we have
been working on on some of that the
retail and registered in the employment
land study and the perhaps key piece of
work that is ongoing at the mall means
the update of the strategic housing
market assessment that will give the
council a figure for objectively
assessed housing need that will be
subject to discussion and debate as the
local client progresses so I'd say there
is you know whole number of reasons why
the local plan has taken somewhat longer
than anticipated the same is true for
the community infrastructure levy the
the knock-on effect of the work on
the plans and legal challenges has meant
that that has been somewhat delayed I'm
not chairing sure that there will be a
substantial loss of money because as
long as we do not fall foul of the
pudding rules and kind to section 16
obligations the council should not
actually lose any money as a result of
the levy being a father deleted than
anticipated come back on that one in
place cherries so we've already lost the
on-site raised line yeah they are quite
substantial developments full road would
have been one that could have been
living over
there are quite large development would
have come in and brought quite a large
amount of money and the community
infrastructure levy has all the other
willful site since websites we've got a
measure to levy money on so the amount
made we've lost live stream as was quite
considerable and the fact that it's
taking two and a half years to do our
folder so one document there has taken
three and a half years an assignment
three revised timetable will be prepared
and the other was take some of them off
years sony is just just sitting off a
lot on the 3rd ID when that one was
aside it's nothing to actually happened
on level 2 i'm in this as well my
classmate pc would come if i want to
make the point that we can't have our
cake and eat it so either we get our
infrastructure relating specifically to
a development through the section 106
while we get it from the infrastructure
levy I don't see that very necessary is
losing money we're just losing the
ability to spend it made me wear with my
shoes as opposed to sociate a
specifically the site I'll agree with
that because upon the section 106
agreements we've had we've had
substantial benefits hopefully for the
district's hope to get much more but
whereas this beautiful structure let me
use very much more structured and if you
like you know it's basically over you
know the head if you like it you can't
change it whereas section 106 agreements
can often from no clearly be negotiated
and it's usually subject to a legal
agreement but you know I take the
members point you know these things are
are delayed but I think there are
reasons for those designs I mean as far
as the first one is concerned with a DS
down as a read anyway as is the last one
so you know I think that's indicated to
members that the reason
the problem did you want to carry on now
on the database all right next page
which is the improve their quality of a
nice and centered by the Declaration of
Air Quality Management Area this has
been declared already repeated class on
time ago side and it says here in effect
on first of every 2015 so basically its
business title says that one should be
completely five something wait when the
way I'm disgusted with Essex County
Council is different now but I think
underneath it explains about gathering
data and potential options for action so
I think there are obviously ongoing
thing you do they're pretty clear on a
Q&A but that's not the end of the story
is it that's all words the beginning of
the story just beginning well then we've
got change the heading nothing right
let's go to the experts provide promote
in-house pride in the district through a
fence with promotion partners I'm just
wondering if anyone actually tell me
what the event was that was being
discussed and done who the actual car
commercial partners alibi talk to us now
it was the first time I thought about
again that's a red isn't it yeah the
tribunal which is prob
nothin Sam to resume so if we go to page
four develop network or cycle paths one
of my favorite leaves their target
completion tapes people had to be
preferred so how can we actually have
something that's forty percent complete
when we've got no completion you into it
we do this time and time again and it
just drives about the world I've been on
this for central plain let me know the
end date is I was they stop competitive
ever i think that means we the
commentary in that you know there is a
feasibility been done and now being
considered but it says as yet no day for
an imitative course this will be done by
third-party be Jimmy Carr County
highways just so we're not a delivering
this over the lines I'm chairing the we
can't set it in D until we've got people
from his expecting early so I think I
understand what piece but for quite
stratum eight unless you can define a
piece of cake or measuring how on earth
you know cut know how many slices
because if it's an infinitely large cake
and I accept that but I equally so I
don't think we should take these bar
charts as being definitive there a
million digital
the next wondrously projected on page
five was that produced transportation
strategy supplement or did you want to
come there from one of those so I hit on
those books I just come back with a
cycle path I plate it all I want to say
is I had a question Lisa's cats i had
some nervous I tend to go through this
before here and then bring out with many
officers if of operations rather than so
they've got time to bring the responses
to this meeting I just magic that may be
a way forward for some of these 1 babli
its many films often the wall practice
isn't it I have done this before but
like oh so that's why I guess both
operators now okay so thank goodness
right so he wants to carry on yeah the
produced transport strategy
supplementary planning document which
amount to sign the shank sampling of the
plate has been going for over a year so
we've actually kind of got a lot 14
months or so to complete it nineteen
ninety percent your faulty months so as
we subscribe so there's a lot of work
going on the background there must be an
awful lot happening underneath or on
that
there's nothing shy page six if you
counsel on the public organization only
land to that five development
opportunities sorry one on this side
yeah we shined their march 2015 and the
ten percent of bleep and shine bread but
if we look at that kind of like we
should finish that joke about 2024 so
I'm very concerned about that one being
so far behind you know there's not like
a sign that one really Molina has been
going for a year it's got a year ago the
10 / 7 sorry Joe conversation with me
and Buddha our record that one because I
bawled out from under an apparently cats
happened awaiting a response on one
judge all the things that one up no
around the freight house encounter is I
two conflicting are two conflicting
responses to this and what's the
gentleman sonoma county's leading on
this Queen would that they are waiting
for us to respond the character habit to
tier 5 companion fighting Carson by
tonight you deform under you refer to
the one public is saying right this is
more incumbency this is relative to
publicly owned land which is presumably
within our portfolio of land of young
which counselor step so next year we'll
have something to say about because the
present time as I understand it from
Mike he's not satisfied about particular
ownership and when they're our portfolio
is in fact
neat so that's called some angst I
believe from you Mike maybe want to
contribute something to that
conversation in a minute so this is far
more in it's all-encompassing as opposed
to the thing you brought up money and
you're quite right on Monday I've
requested figures relative to the
freight house with respect to
constructing a office block there as
opposed to housing and until we get them
i can't i can't are not content until
I've got those figures to determine in
my mind how I would like to go forward
and each of us will have a vote in that
but at the time on content because we
have those so how can council members
they're not presented with all the
options how can you possibly make a
judgment you can't so I've suggested to
a mile and I probably capsule off so
this des is Kelly we know it then we're
not going there I've suggested to green
I asked him for it of all of the three
months ago four months ago and it's not
been forthcoming as too much question
directly but there were some fingers for
and an aim our control
ND perfect well I'm disgruntled about it
and when we got all the figures we can
send simply sit down discuss it and make
sure until we've got them come or the
Cubist a squad whatever yeah welcome
back just like you not bad one obviously
when you've got all the figures and the
variable options I would like to be
consulted on that it could be optional
mouth or your home's also any benefit to
the community which I've already
waukesha joke it will know to fall
Council this is nothing for me to do it
with personally so if you're getting the
impression that something I'm doing
diversity it's rockered i'm not i'm
merely a single counselor who perhaps
has quite a lot of involvement of the
day-to-day basis with officers and so on
and i've seen something which i'm not
content with so therefore i've requested
that we have the full gambit so that we
understand what's available what we can
do what we can't do what makes sense
what doesn't make sense hey don't stack
up financially but chocolate the figures
i won't know excellent thank you ok
moving on already bored ok they're equal
to minus 2 life ok Ricky's stops under
my thunder there it's I have been
concerned about the accuracy of our
register for a number of reasons and I
do know he is being looked into but I
must admit it is and it seems to be
taking the one thinking but cord current
release Delia page seven first item was
investigated capsules developed land
alone or in partnership yet again it's
my favorite now in David the next item
down the development Doppler the
development magic plan are just like you
to take notes of the racks layers and
layers completely great that's just a
note later on next items attention to
myself this is empty home screen temper
como is no longer there while get your
card showing it and if it is still there
for doing this will be 6 months level
that's only 35 superbly so that one
would worry me something fantastic with
office has been finished each term
loving the issue here is is that there
are some outstanding funds that would if
distributed to districts would enable
some further progress to be made them on
that scheme sort of the end game as it
were of that scheming I think that's set
agent in the nose yeah I'm not a word
that we've reported over
myvi so the scheme can still carries on
those funds are exhausted after it goes
page eight it's about 30 min do you see
my own strategy into this is six months
late and I thought great she thought I
think we're good chairman the empty room
strategy is been the key decisions for
April so it will be coming to the
portfolio Mulder with the report okay
still six months late right promote
energy efficiency and type of fuel
pontoons do for one their target
completion date I'm going so yeah yeah
again with twenty five percent on that
one run guys game so that's how long is
a piece of string and then we wouldn't
they we've got the page nine I'm sorry
page nine right the first one now you
will see the reason I asked you to note
the reg status how growth of new and
existing businesses back starts
breathing as 100 single bleep the
previous ones grade and complain one
middle is great and complete the bottom
looks 100 central references completed
on time so we're not exactly consistent
with ourselves are we when it comes to
our own statuses maybe it's going point
but it's really all the same next one
you'll be pledged to say our way through
say about those yeah submitted their
loud and it will relate at least we
round up should be ready but some image
with that [ __ ] out as part of property
should be major problem because it is
six months late
therefore the last page about this one
laughs yeah I really do like this one
this one's the top one then finishing
March and we are relatives of sectors
clean it says that the gun the file has
been secured but still we've got
finished fifty percent it minus five
weeks something that would be nice to do
that one and the other one which I know
that Miss described is going to say it's
going some counseling April is the three
developed and adopted three town centre
protraction pains or design to as ones
will be been adopted so that's the first
point if the skeins are the actual
committee in April then the Slater's
that will not be read but when you
actually read the bottom part the same
watch for the site I AP in post a
notification stage and your doctor
special angel but the other one will not
be adopting anticipated to alternative
2015 so I mean yeah we're not doing too
well so that placing for chairman is
that reports for as officer and I hope
you do it ever okay well I think some of
these reports will change where they as
the new assistant or its as Benny and I
appreciate that they're always as
accurate as they could be I think we've
ordered reports already be made that in
Cottonwood rely on the percentages
relate to other things but I think as I
sort of gay just where we are and as a
tool for this committee I think you like
fulfill the purpose in that obviously
can only be as accurate as people make
them I don't even be able to make any
connection at all yes please Thank You
Jane I I realized that a lot of these
items assumingly behind I think the
first report we looked at which we made
the comments on there were lot of items
within that report which actually
highlighted the fact that something was
in the planning area there are quite a
few vacancies we've lost quite a few
staff due to the assessment and of
course this is an ongoing thing and this
will have to be sorted in the fullness
of time hopefully that we've been
quicker but I wouldn't like the
situation where we have a panic when we
need to take people on from this
unlikely
the job and I feel that that's the most
important thing yes there is concern
here and maybe there are certain items
within this that realistically need a
bit better attention when they're being
reported because as counsel Gordon is
quite likely said there are quite a few
anomalies which you know when you read
them done particularly nice sense and I
think that's a problem so that's just
the why don't we put together they are
not correct on the degree but there are
the college trees underneath which do
attempt to explain yourselves anybody
else want to come in on a report its
general I would say yet there are new
directors in place they are now going
through and looking at all these reports
and I'm certain that the next and
reporting stage their vehicle scratch
one thing and I don't think I'm aims and
portfolios any different from any
affairs but councillor Gordon's
highlighted them and I'm sure the
directors will take call them okay
anybody else will Terry you will
recollect that it's just the last time
you'll get them in this form only
anywhere
there's no okay yep thank you right so
this these plants 201 so is mine keep
those plays are not so you don't
understand I'm sponsors happy down to
something Bob Johnny right so progress
and decisions made and anybody wish to
raise anything on any of the pages
please so there's note the report to
thank you gets the last item image in
this chair okay so thank you very much
members or close the meeting thank you